good morning hey fantastic
it's so nice to be in a room full of
human beings
this is oh you're going to hear this all
day today all the speakers are like
really excited to be back and oh it's
real people instead of my computer
screen at home and a camera
i get feedback and that's very exciting
um
i am really really excited about what
i'm going to talk about this morning i
usually get excited about things
um about a year and a year and a half
ago now maybe a bit less
i accidentally made something up
um it's called cupid
so what i want to do this morning is
explain a bit about why i made it up and
then what's been happening in the year
since i made up and uh tell you what it
is
and
my goal with this is for
you to tell me what you think okay i am
here
pitching an idea if you like pitching a
model
and my goal is feedback okay so i really
really want to hear what you think i
will try and have some time at the end
for questions anyone who's been to my
talks before knows the the diminishing
likelihood of that
but um
anyway so so let's let's start let's
start uh
a way back
where did this come from this came from
actually it came from ndc in fact it
came from ndc in 2017
and after nbc
there is um
there's an event called pubconf what's
happening here
my clicker
is doing strange things luckily
whoa
i have a backup clicker
because these people are so organized
watch this
wow
thank you organized av people i love you
so um pubcom pubconf is a
it's it's a kind of tongue-in-cheek
after-party thing for ndc
and the rules are it's a brilliant idea
the rules are you didn't go to ndc
right you can only go so for people who
couldn't get tickets because ndc usually
sells out
um it's quite an expensive event to go
to is particularly if you're funding
yourself
and so
a couple of folks put together this idea
of ndc of pubconf
which is they grab some speakers from
ndc
and you give a five minute talk
and it's a five minute what's called an
ignite style talk so an ignite talk is
you have 20 slides and they advance
automatically every 15 seconds
okay and you can write your own talk
which is what i did or they do nowadays
they do this like an improv type of
thing so they just throw some slides at
you and they just keep changing and you
have to riff along to those
anyway they said look daniel
do you want to come out do you want to
give a talk at pubconf and i
stupidly said yes it turns out the
amount of work that goes into a
five-minute talk is mind-bogglingly more
than goes into a one-hour talk
so i said yeah i'm gonna do this um
in particular what i was thinking about
was solid at the time so those of you
who don't know solid is an acronym made
of five principles um
originally uh written up documented
communicated by robert c martin and
when he was working at a company called
object mental which i think he founded
so he's working with a chap called mike
feathers who wrote the brilliant working
effectively with legacy code
and mike feathers noticed that if you
rearrange the first five of these
principles in a particular order it's
felt solid
and these are the single responsibility
principle the open close principle lisk
of substitutability principle interface
uh segregation
principle and dependency inversion there
we go i just i've said them so many
times now i i still can't tell you no um
so anyway
and i had been looking at these and the
main reason i've been looking at these
is this is i've been writing software
in various forms and various kind of
guises for about 30 years
and i looked at solid and the problem i
had with it it was like it's neither
necessary nor sufficient
so for each of those things
um i can take a look at single
responsibility principle
or interface segregation or whatever it
is and i can say yeah there are a bunch
of places where i wouldn't bother doing
that
and there's a bunch of places where if i
did that i'm still in trouble
or ironically i'm in more trouble
right and i'll explain that in a second
anyway so i so
the reason i wanted to talk about solid
at this talk
um at this pub conference talk was
because i'm lazy
and my plan was this solid five things
okay one slide to introduce it 15
seconds one slide to disagree with it 15
seconds one slide to say what i do
instead 15 seconds that's 15 slides top
and tail it i'm done
right and so i did
and we did this pubcomp thing and it was
fun and you know lots of people drank
beer and stamped their feet and it was
awesome and then i did a made a fatal
mistake of putting the slides online
at which point the the craftsman the
software craftsman which is the secret
name of the
bob martin solid cult
came after me with pitchforks
and boy they were crossed but they were
crossed in a spectacular self-owned kind
of way so there were some brilliant you
know when i say brilliant i mean
spiteful ad hominem blog posts about why
every element of dan north is wrong
um but they you know even in the way it
was richard said now this man just makes
stuff up and has straw man arguments
whilst making up straw man arguments
about what i'd said you know this person
doesn't even bother contacting the
author of the without contacting me
i'm like
i don't need to respond to your post
because you already did right um
anyway some people got crossed so and
that was it that was what all i thought
was going to happen
until last february
so february 21.
um there's extreme tuesday club is i
think the longest running xp or agile
kind of meetup in the world certainly
one of them started in the early 2000s
in london in a pub
and a lot of this takes place in pubs
as i'm saying this out loud
um so uh
the extreme tuesday club has now moved
online because pandemic and world's
ending and so they happened that topic
that week happened to be solid
and one of the organizers contacted me
and said look you know you did that that
thing where you poked at solid a couple
of years ago i was like yeah well we're
talking about solid if you're not a fan
of solid what would you have instead
i was like
that's a really good question
like maybe i can come up with five
principles that aren't solid and then i
was like you know there's a bigger
question which is are there are there
five principles that are universally
applicable to software right is that
even a non-question right
and so i came up with cupid and i came
up with cupid deliberately firstly it
was near valentine's day
right but also i wanted something that
was so not solid
right and that the kind of the the the
um the code craftsman bros
would just go oh no that's just two no
i'm not gonna say that
um and the great thing about this and
kevin and henny will tell you this as
well
because he's done this is when you start
with an acronym and then make up the
thing is it called a background
okay
you end up in a world of fun because now
you've got loads of candidates for each
of the letters
and there's a whole load of blog posts
that i haven't written about some of the
kind of the the runners-up if you like
the shortlist for some of the letters
and why i end up with the ones i've got
and so anyway so that's what happened
and then what i did is i became um and
this is how most of my work i've
realized over the years
most of the stuff i produce is for other
people's deadlines
i have my own deadlines they go
whooshing past right when it's someone
else when they say can you come and
speak at our conference i'm like yes of
course crap
i've got to put something together now
so now i had to explain what this was so
um
this was early early to um early 20 2021
and then i started talking about it
and then i scared them talking about it
and talking about it and i got some
really really good feedback and it was
really encouraging and i got excited
about that and then i finally a year
later wrote it up really i've been
threatening to write up cupid for a
while i finally wrote it up
um and it appeared on the front page of
hacker news
no i i didn't post it i don't actually
read hacker news but
it's something that happens if someone
posts your stuff and you end up on
hacker news suddenly you get a lot of
traffic to your website
so there i was slightly disappointingly
on the 15th
of february
but i know off by one error right
but um but that was fun and then the
maddest thing happened and the maddest
thing is that i'm now on footworks tech
radar
okay so so this kind of riff on an idea
and it turned out and it's not you know
okay i can sort of be all
humble bragging and all that i spent a
lot of time thinking about this and the
reason it's ended up there is because it
does resonate it's resonating with a lot
of people
and the feedback i'm hearing is we're
using this
we're using this model we're using this
way of articulating code
in our day jobs and it's helping and so
that makes me very happy
um and then so that's what happens to
your website
right so
i'm not very good at websiting i'm not
very good at um yeah i don't have a
newsletter i don't blog regularly i'm
really infrequent and then so what
happens is you end up with like you see
50 000 views
uh 61 000 views um
news dot y combinator so that's hack and
news 10 000 visitors from that one post
um
and then twitter thoughtworks that's the
tech radar a couple of thousand from
there
so suddenly you get all this traffic and
then
crickets
so my website is mostly crickets so
okay
what i want to do before we get into
the cupid acronym itself is set the
scene a bit
um
who are we writing code for when we
write software who are we writing code
for that's a question you can call
things out
compiler you're writing code for
compilers yep okay that's true
future me i think is my favorite answer
to this future me yes future me you're
writing what else
other developers
um this martin fowler
pretty much opens the refactoring book
1996 with this quote
any fool can write code that a computer
can understand compilers right
good programmers write code that humans
can understand
and i remember not just the idea of
refactoring that was really profound for
me that statement
i probably came across 20 odd years ago
or something
that statement has just stayed in in my
back of my head in my operating memory
ever since
what i also realized again because when
you start giving talks about things you
think about them more deeply and you
iterate on them
is one of the reasons that solid itself
and
you know again i people say i bash solid
i don't i think solid of its time was
brilliant
right of its time the way we thought
about software in the late 80s early 90s
software was something that you'd build
and then you put it there and you build
the next thing they put it there and so
code files source files typically cc
plus plus
files um
well you know right only you know you'd
write it and then you'd move to the next
thing and you'd layer in layer and layer
and what that meant is that um going
back and changing things was unusual and
typically risky
also
people didn't tend to sit together we
hadn't really co-located people by this
point so something like um you know
there was single responsibility separate
ui logic from business logic from data
access
isn't really so much about code as about
the human dynamics of this the the
people changing that code are likely in
different teams
right and they're not going to talk to
each other because they're not allowed
to talk to each other because that's how
the organization's structured and when
something needs to change it probably
needs to change in all three of those
places you change the data and you
change the rules about that data and you
change how it looks but different people
are going to do that work
and if they're all tromping over the
same source file that's bad
okay so something like single
responsibility is a way of protecting
ourselves against
parentheses something that no longer
exists
right
likewise list of substitutability if you
have subtypes make them apply the
principle of least surprise don't make
them be
pathological compared to their super
types first thing the clues in the word
types this is not about hierarchical
class-based oo languages this is about
type systems
but viewed through a c plus lens it
looks an awful lot like subclasses
right
and also we don't really do that so much
you know we've all decided or most of us
have decided that composition is a much
better way of putting code together than
inheritance
so we've got really good advice for
something we don't really do anymore
and what occurred to me recently is this
refactoring
largely
makes the makes the rest of solid
redundant
right we were scared of changing code
and solid was about making code more
stable
right making it more more resilient
because we didn't want to go back and
muck around with it or if we did we
wanted to be safe doing it and then
refactoring said honestly it's like clay
you'll be fine
right and the patterns that martin came
up with in the 90s became the tooling we
use now became you know alt shift f7 we
don't even think about it now
right refactoring deterministic ast
based refactoring is muscle memory
wow
right anyway so
i looked at that and i understand can we
do better than understand
i mean understand is table stakes right
and then um again kevin i'm going to
name check kevlin because he introduced
me to this quote
um and then i went and read the paper
the article by dick gabriel um so the
paper is called habitability and
piecemeal growth
and there's a whole set of like an
anthology of papers called patterns of
software from that again in the 90s
and dick gabriel this is just it's a
beautiful piece of writing go and read
the whole article he says he says
habitability is the characteristic of
source code that enables and he lists a
whole bunch of different kinds of people
to understand its construction and
intentions and to change it comfortably
and confidently
okay and then he says habitability makes
a place livable like home
and that really again resonated with me
because we as programmers we live in
that code
right if you live in a messy home
that's really hard to get anything done
in you're going to just feel that drag
all the time if you live in a home full
of booby traps right
then then you're going to kind of not
really want to open doors too often yeah
and so i thought i'll have a stability
habitable that sounds better than
understandable
what about joyful what if we could go
beyond habitable and code that just
makes you happy
right just a quick straw poll
who here
has and i'm looking across the room and
i'm seeing it's quite interesting
actually ndc is an interesting
demographic i'm seeing quite an older
demographic here i'm gonna just as quick
hands up have you been coding more than
ten years
wow uh oh about two-thirds of them keep
your hands up keep your hands up 15
years
20 years
yeah about a third of the room more than
20 years thank you so
okay
all the people in the room put your hand
up if you have experienced joyful code
you've gone into a code base an
unfamiliar code base you like with
trepidation and fear and all those usual
emotions and you've gone
wait
this looks awesome
i i understand this i don't put your
hands up if you if you've had that
experience
ah depressingly few non-zero which is
great but i'm gonna say less than ten
percent of the hands
right isn't it a great feeling right
wouldn't it be nice to give that feeling
to someone else
think about a code base that's been
joyful to work with right
can you describe can you articulate what
makes that code base joyful
is it a just it just was it's just a
hunch it's just a feeling just is how we
it's a diminutive applied to instinct
applied to feelings because as
logical rational humans we don't like to
think that feelings are first-class
actors in our lives spoiler they are
right we all make predictably irrational
decisions can we describe what makes it
joyful
and
what kind of properties does does joyful
code have and i'm using the word
properties very deliberately here
i tried thinking of principles and what
i realized is i don't think in
principles
okay
and then it occurred to me that maybe we
don't think in principles we're just
going to have them inflicted on us let
me explain what i mean principles are
basically rules
the guidelines right do these things
so
they
give you conditions they give you
boundaries okay
and you either conform to the condition
or it's wrong
so this wonderful chat paul paul hebert
and paul hebert's a missiologist i
learned this word a few years ago
missiologist is someone who studies
missionaries christian missionaries
and he's working for various church
organizations and he's looking at
missionaries in different contexts
and he's trying to see as an
anthropologist is there what makes some
missionaries more successful than others
you know they go into a community
they're welcomed by the community they
figure out how to all get along you know
there's lasting change in that community
versus people who go in
typically kind of you know like the
colonial sort of go in and impose their
thing on someone and also typically as
soon as they leave it just regresses
they're like they're gone yet
haven't said that right as you were
everyone
and he came up with this idea he's a
mathematician as well so he come with
this idea of bounded versus centered
sets
or bounded versus centered communities
and the idea is this is with a boundary
set you have boundary markers and
boundary markers might be the clothes
you wear the uh the food you eat or
don't eat rules you follow vocabulary
vocabulary is a great boundary marker if
you know the words right do you know do
you use the same utterances as me
and what happens with a bounded
community is you spend all of the time
the community spends all the time
guarding its boundary
certification is a brilliant boundary
marker you have a scrum certificate or
you don't
right so
and then you guard the boundaries and
you forget why you even had the set
you forget what the community was about
because everyone's now about guarding
the boundary
a centered community is more kind of
values based it says this is what we
believe
there's no outside
and there's no insight there's just
closer to or further from
okay and wherever you are you can always
move closer to and wherever you are you
can always move further from
and he found he found that his research
found that
missionaries who create
centered communities they were much much
more resilient long-lasting communities
they long outlasted the missionary
and that sense of belonging and
centeredness and having shared values
again you'll see this in open source
communities the ones that are thriving
and active and exciting and all of those
things i see this in the cucumber
community right the bdd tool cucumber
i'm not a community builder so when i
see it in other people i think it's
astonishing john skeeter's a brilliant
community builder
so azlak hellesoy started this thing and
matt win came along later and what they
do is this they've got these mailing
lists and you join the mailing list and
someone asks a beginner question now i
grew up with usenet in the 90s right and
and immediately it was like really the
faq you know reader who are you read the
faq and in fact typically when you join
the mail a news group that you're going
to automated mail saying here's our faq
there's 200 questions you're like oh
crap
and what happens in the cucumber list
and it's great thing to watch
is people ask the same questions again
and again and again at every time
someone like aslak or matt or someone
says hi
welcome to the community let's talk
about your question
i know like the patience of these people
but also the impact that has on the
community because now everyone else in
the community does that too right
so centered communities are much much
more value-based community much more
powerful so properties now are qualities
or characteristics
these describe the center
they just find a goal or a center
and our code is only ever closer to or
further from
it's not wrong
right so what you get with principles
and boundaries is police and you get the
solid police yeah
um
let's turn my phone off um and you know
and then slowly please come and go
that's not that's violating the single
responsibility principle and they have a
checklist
you're in violation and they ticket you
so with a with a property-based um
you know the set of properties rather
than principles you're only ever closer
or further
and then it gets a bit better right if
we're going to have properties what
properties should those properties have
yeah
so
i want them to be practical
i don't want abstract arcane complicated
any of that stuff i want it to be easy
for me to describe them and easy for you
to describe them to each other to
articulate easy for you to assess
take a look you know how to what extent
is our code this and easy to adopt it's
not an all or nothing thing it's so just
take whatever you need and it might be
helpful
um i want to be human
and it's a very deliberate term so
if you look at solid and a lot of these
other kind of code health things
is from the perspective of the code
so i want to look at this from the
perspective of human beings of us as
human being programmers looking at code
working with code
so for instance again single
responsibilities was a great example
it's about how the code changes reasons
for the code to change code should have
one reason to change
okay it's not necessarily about you
working with that code
and the third thing i want is a bit of
nuance
so you know
programming isn't black and white
properties aren't black and white you
know as i said it's there's a whole lot
of nuance moving towards what i want is
that i can teach this to junior
programmers to novices to people who've
never programmed before and say hey look
here are some things to think about code
and you can look at code you can have
opinions right and and it might you know
this might be useful for you but then
once you've been around for a bit and
you're like
but why is it let's let's let's dig into
this thing then you see layers and
nuance and you can really kind of chew
on some of these things
so okay that's it here's the reveal and
then i'm going to do this and then you
can all just check your email now
because the restaurant i'm just going to
talk about this some more
so the c is composable
code should be composable it should play
well with others
okay
um you unix philosophy
so unix is 50 years old 50 something
years old so am i me and unix are about
the same age
um unix does one thing what so so the
point about unix one of the things that
makes it enduring that makes it gives
its longevity is this idea that in unix
every command does one thing one and
only one thing and it does it well
and that is the the place that does that
again i'm going to unpack each of these
separately
predictable
it does what i expect it doesn't expect
again and again if it's failing if it's
buggy it's the same buggy each time
because if it's different buggy each
time
i'm in a world of asynchronous hurt
idiomatic
idiomatic you write code like everyone
else writes code
right idiomatic is hard for people with
big egos
because it means you have to leave your
ego at the door and some people don't
like that
some people really struggle with that
make your code look like everyone else's
code even if everyone else's code is
wrong
right that's hard
sam newman gave me one of my favorite he
doesn't remember saying this i remember
being in the room when he said this
we were on a project in 2005 or
something
and again it was something about the way
web logic if anyone remembers web logic
application server was configured i'm
like it's that's not how you do it and
he said right but it's not how you do it
on seven of the eight machines let's
make it also not how you do it on the
eighth machine
and he said i'd rather things are
inconsistent are consistently wrong than
inconsistently anything
and i was enlightened
right you know what they're consistently
wrong we've now we can now consistently
move them forward too consistently
better
and d domain based
and again we're going to unpack these so
domain based in not just in language not
just ddd but in structure and the way we
structure code as well okay
so let's take a look at these composable
then composable
code that's easy to use gets used and
used
and used and used again right if it's
easy for me to
make sense of your code
i can then quickly make a decision about
that code
okay i like code i like components with
a small surface area
okay um exactly what uh rich campbell
was talking about in his opening keynote
he says you know
the difference between say apache and
iis or something like node.js is apache
iis had came with all the tools out you
know there's hundreds and hundreds of
things you could do massive surface area
know just when what you want
at the moment i do nothing can you do
nothing and be a web server yes
can you do nothing and be a web server
and read a file yes
yes and so gradually you kind of bolt
bits onto it
so
small surface area and again actually
using nodes a really good example of
this because in node
typically every single module
has two things it's an event emitter and
an event consumer and if you understand
events you've pretty much got node down
right it gets a bit more funky with
promises and stuff but promises are just
a way for human beings to manage the
asynchrony of events
right it's all you know when you get to
this events all the way down till you
get to turtles
small surface area there's less to learn
less to go wrong less to conflict i
i think the very first open source thing
i wrote is called a thing called xjb and
i know we're mostly a microsoft gang
here i grew up on the on the enterprise
java side if you never saw enterprise
java you're lucky
if you did i hope the p the ptsd
counselling is going well
um
so
uh yeah so so in particular
like testing unit there's no unit
testing in jtv was insane so ibm had
like the biggest the the largest market
share things called websphere and
website took about a minute to start
right your container took a minute to
start before you could run your unit
test and then tear it down so imagine a
minute transaction cost per unit test
before you've even started the test
right
so i wrote a thing called xjb which is
like testing ejbs but outside the
container and they would start in
microseconds or whatever and that was
fun
and i showed it to my buddy and i said
hey look at this i wrote some open
source he said that's great why has it
got a dependency on log for j i'm like
well because i need logging in there he
said well i don't
if i want to use your thing i'll use my
own logging so again but everyone's
using log for j i said yeah but what if
they're not or what if they're using a
different version
you just made it harder for me to adopt
your thing that's right that's
annoyingly true
so so i took out all of the logging and
just put in hooks you know if you want
to plug in your own login you can here's
what you'll get but you don't need
anything
suddenly loads of people using it
okay i it hadn't occurred to me that
something that was convenient for me as
a developer was going to be potentially
a massive handicap or even just a deal
breaker for someone else who wanted to
use my stuff
okay small surface area less to go wrong
less to conflict
versions
make it say its name we all love we all
love a silverlight pun
right
um
there's there's a story there's a story
that's um selenium
the web testing tool
uh which came out about the same time hp
had mercury test director whatever it's
called mercury sweet this huge massive
suite selenium is the antidote to
mercury poisoning
okay which is cute and clever and not
intentional revealing at all
okay
give it an intentional revealing name
because i'm more likely to find it
and make it easier to discover easy to
evaluate i'm a massive fan of like the
two-minute tutorial the ten minute
tutorial two minute tutorial says look
at this within two minutes you're going
to determine whether or not it's useful
and then there's another thing that
within 10 minutes you'll be able to
determine whether it's right for you in
this context
okay and if you can't write if you can't
explain it in two minutes or ten minutes
it's probably too complicated
and i want minimal dependencies again um
the late wonderful joe armstrong he said
this he said this about object-oriented
languages he says you want a banana but
you've got a whole gorilla
right as opposed to say erlang where you
just have messages that's the whole
thing the whole of erlang is processes
and messages in mailboxes that's it i'll
just describe the entire language
right in one sentence genius you wanted
a banana but you got a whole gorilla you
got the whole jungle yeah
so minimal dependence is small surface
area
once that's true or if you move towards
that center
you're more likely to make something
that i can find useful i can repurpose
and it might be future eye right it
might be future me doing this
okay you unix philosophy
so
again unix started in the in the late
60s i started in the late 60s
and it's still going it's it's on every
single right it's on your phone if
you're running uh you've got an android
phone it's on your mac it's on windows
windows now has
first-class support linux pretty much
won the unix wars but there's still
other unixes out there
and even when we had in the 90s what
were called the unix wars so each you
had hardware vendors and each hardware
vendor would have their own version of
unix that ran exclusively on their
hardware so hp ibm
um
deck there are a whole bunch of these
different hardware companies sun
all had their own versions of unix
but they all had this core at the center
of
each program does one thing well ls
ls lists files
okay um here's the thing ls doesn't know
about files
there's another command that you
probably won't use on a command line
called stat
or fstat and stat knows about files and
devices and things and it goes in and it
pulls that it gives you a record the
structured record of data that tells you
what kind of thing it is is it a file is
it a directory is it a tape fifo
lifo device fifo device
and so on or is it a network device
that's pretending to be a file
stat comes and gives you information ls
just formats it so ls is actually a file
information formatter
it doesn't list files it doesn't list
directories and so each of these things
works because it does one thing well
and then it's designed to be composable
when you add combine that with
composability
you can make
anything so you can take any set of text
and you can do anything with it cat
gives me the contents of a file or maybe
it might not be a file it might be a
random number generator or it might be a
network device that's sucking from a
website i don't know
but cat grep then filters that text said
then replaces the filtered text sort
then sorts that and then unique removes
duplicates and so on and so on and so on
so any type of text transformation
is trivial
right or certainly doable
right based on these these little atoms
of functionality so unix is like for me
is the epitome of composability and and
doing one thing well
but surely that's the same as srp
no
again srp is from the inside looking out
do one thing is from the outside looking
in so
from the from the srp perspective that
says you know different people are going
to want to change this code for
different reasons put them in separate
places
okay
um when the different people work in
different teams and maybe different
companies yes sure
when they're in the same team or when
they're the same person who now does ui
stuff and they and business logic stuff
and data stuff because it's just
programming
then actually you just give them admin
to do
right
so
yeah it's about what the code does not
how the code changes
okay
so then
predictable
um
i think of predictable as a
generalization
of testable
okay so
i came back in his four four um rules of
of of code one of his rules first one is
passes all the tests
like does it work
uh i'm like yeah but even when there's
no tests
and i asked at the beginning who's
experienced joyful code i first
experienced joyful code i've been super
lucky in my career and i think it was
probably 91 i was like straight out of
college in my first job
and i was learning c on the job i was
hired as a c programmer with no c i was
a i was a graduate engineer i've done
like pascal and some stuff at college
um as these are ancient
so pascal is old enough you you actually
write it in hieroglyphs
you carve it into clay and then there's
some people come and yeah
um
but then that did become turbo pascal
which became dealthy which was awesome
and then got killed
uh but then so yeah but so i'm i'm early
in my career and my first job was
working for a digital image processing
company so digital image processing is
you have uh four color printing cy
magenta yellow black
and you have lots and lots of pixels on
a on a print page and each of those has
a color which is a four four of the a4
number number
vector
and what would happen is we're doing
color correction so the idea is you have
an image a photo of something
and you want that photo to come out
looking that color when you print it
well all printing is different
and so what you do is you would print it
and then you'd rescan it and then you
could do some color correction and that
was basically putting it through a four
by four sort of matrix of all the
possible color combinations
so that then you're doing a transform of
every single dot on the page to its
color corrected version so hugely
complicated graphics processing software
and a time when like gpus weren't a
thing yet for another 10 years
and
i'm there i'm fairly new and there's a
bug
right there's a but what we know is
there's a bug
there's a bug and it's somewhere in the
code
hey new kid i need you to go into the
code and find the bug i'm like okay
i'll see you in three weeks right
so so i went into the code and and i had
that moment i was like
but i understand this
and i know i know it's not because i'm a
good c programmer because i'm making
this up so it must be whoever wrote it
left it for someone who's not a good
programmer to read
yes thank you whoever that was
and i literally in minutes
i would navigate in the code it was
really obvious where all the call points
were and where all where i should jump
off and and i isolated this bug and i
kid you not it was in a for loop and it
was a less than instead of a greater
than it was a simple simple logic error
one character change
okay and i made the one character change
pretty confident we didn't have unit
tests or tdd or anything like that then
it was just you know
i made the one character change and then
i rebuilt the app reborn the upstate
several hours right compiling's fast
linking
all the c people c plus plus wolf
um
you kids today
anyway so some time later but then we
ran it and i was pretty confident hey i
was pretty confident i found the bug
i was pretty confident i fixed the bug
and more importantly this was called
impact analysis i was pretty confident i
hadn't caused any more damage
right
and do you know what it worked
and i take none of the credit
okay all of the credit goes to
the people because it was more than one
person the people who had designed this
thing the people who had agreed between
them
that they were going to do it this way
that they were going to keep each other
honest the idiot graduate kid was going
to rock up and be able to make sense of
it
right
thank you then
yeah
so when there's no tests
if it's predictable if the code is
predictable oh man that's a joyful thing
yeah
i was working on much more recently i
was working on
algorithmic trading software which does
use gpus
very very high performing very
firewall of a fire hose of data coming
in of market data
thousands of messages a second you're
trying to make sense of this and trade
algorithmically at the same time
we built this stack from basically
nothing up to a very profitable set of
suite of software
and at one point i think about a year
into this i ran a code coverage
metric on the code base
what was our um you know where
i'd say rabid ex-peers right everyone on
the team's a small team about four or
five people all of us rabbit xp is what
was our test coverage what was our tdd
code coverage on this highly technical
um codebase
have a guess
two so what kind of amateur cowboys
think we are two percent uh seven
seven percent
um code coverage uh
here's the thing
it was not evenly distributed
lots and lots and lots of the code base
had no test because it didn't need them
because the code was so obvious i mean
you literally it was like write these
two lines what what test you gonna write
for that isn't just double entry
bookkeeping
right it just works it's so simple and
so obvious that it couldn't do anything
else
and then you get into the thing that did
what's called order management order
management is a
massively asynchronous very high data
volume state machine
and we made up we invented kinds of
testing for that
right and we were very very confident
that it worked or at least that it
worked to everything we could think of
and some things we couldn't and so
so past all the tests yeah sure but when
you don't have tests that's still a
thing
but it's not just about behavior it's
not just about functionality it's that i
want to see what it's like when it's
running
okay so it does the same thing every
time even if it's buggy it's buggy the
same way every time
but it's operating characteristics i
know how much memory it uses i know how
much cpu you use i know if i see it
start spiking that's probably a bad
thing
or i know if i see it start spiking
that's completely normal and it's going
to level out and go down again in a
minute
there it goes right we're back it's all
fine right i know when i should be
nervous yeah
and so this is all about observability
and you know i love that observability
is becoming a thing rather than
monitoring i know charity majors mipsy
tipsy has been banging on about this for
probably over a decade
um in a very sweary way but lots of
other people as well are now picking up
that you you can't make something
observable
you design an observable thing
okay it's a characteristic of a system
you build and so observability is a
again a part of predictability
this is where it gets interesting
because this is where you get into like
opinions okay
so i'm a fan and it took me a long time
to realize this like again to articulate
it
and one of the great things and it is a
huge indulgence
being allowed to give a talk
being invited to give a talk
it's an indulgence in that you get to
noodle on something
really really really deeply i mean i
presume most of you are in rich
campbell's keynote just then i was
sitting there about 45-15 minutes in
just like my jaw the amount of research
the amount of just leg work that went
into that talk that little history
lesson
is as someone who puts talks together is
staggering
right and
part of it is like wow that's a huge
amount of work for someone to do but the
other part of it is like it's almost
envy right he got to totally nerd out on
the history of microsoft in the last 20
years
right and i get to totally nerd out on
this so idiomatic code
is this you use the language idioms
okay which means you you need to study
the language okay
when um
so i worked at thoughtworks for about
eight years in the 2000s
and one of the things that they did they
were very very early adopters of dot net
practically as soon as dot net came out
thoughtworks said yeah we're going to do
that
we're going to help companies do that
and how many net people do we have none
they just invented it right
but here's our bet
our bet is this c sharp is a competitor
to java right.net is a competitor to the
j to the jvm and the java runtime
and they are playing in the same
enterprise space
the problems
the problems that you will be solving in
c sharp won't be c sharp problems
they will be business problems we're
really good at that so we're going to be
really good at that in this new
technology
okay so
you know language idioms are might be um
the way you solve problems uh martin
fowler again right this wonderful book
um patterns of application architecture
and there's got all these design
patterns and refactoring patterns these
are patterns of how businesses work
because there are standard repeatable
patterns of how businesses work
language idioms i want to understand the
standard features the constructs
libraries frameworks tools okay i need
to learn those things
because here's the thing i i learned
python probably about 12 years ago i
started doing python
and i was very much ruby i liked ruby
python was weird because white space hey
that's wrong
um turns out it's completely fine right
um but i learned python and so i started
writing python all my python was objects
and classes and methods because i came
from java
and so i wasn't writing python i was
writing java in python
and it turns out that when you start
writing python in python
all the code goes away
it's weird it's like runnable pseudocode
and so so for instance the python the
brilliant brilliant python sort of
default test framework is called pi test
and the built-in one is called test unit
which is
um based on j-unit and s-unit and all of
those so you have a test case class and
it has methods and each method is a test
and all of that
and then pi test said uh
yeah i think that
you're gonna have a function
called test something if you have a
function called test something i'll run
it
well how are you gonna how are you gonna
assert things we're gonna use the word
assert
built into the language right assert a
equals equals b
and when it fails i'm going to give you
the best looking error messages you've
ever seen
i will practically fix your test for you
right
it's really but the whole thing is that
python itself has a
mindset it has a culture there's a word
pythonic
right
there's a wonderful easter egg in python
if you go to command line and you run
python minus m this
or in a python file import this
and it doesn't do anything it's a no op
import with a side effect and the side
effect is it prints
a bunch of aphorisms about python
it says things like explicit is better
than implicit
right there should only be one obvious
way to do things yeah a bunch of just
good programming advice but it's the
python way
and when you learn when you start to
write python like python people
suddenly a your code becomes much much
more understandable to you in python but
more importantly
right future you or not you
are the python people
and so
learning the idioms and using the idioms
means that you're writing for everyone
else in that
ecosystem
and writing code for other people in an
ecosystem is a very humbling thing it's
a very powerful thing
it's a brilliant brilliant communication
thing
this is how you write habitable code as
you write it in an idiomatic way
and what does idiomatic mean well it
might mean
the way the world does things is a bit
different from how we do things here
okay so we it's kind of layered so
you've got like how the world does stuff
um
how we do stuff in our organization and
then within that how we do stuff in our
team or in this particular code base
and
those things may not exist
and so what you'll find is that certain
languages are more opinionated more
idiomatic more obviously idiomatic than
others so
i again i'm from a java heritage so i
tend to use uh scala and clojure as like
the opposite ends of the spectrum here
but maybe i know something like f sharp
and c sharp would be pretty good right
in c sharp you can write
the same looping construct in half a
dozen different ways
you know you've got closures you've got
four loops you've got iterators you've
got um
what's it called um
[Music]
sort of function chaining so that
there's a bunch of different ways to do
that and he's like great okay so what
should we use
the answer is yes
what do you mean yes oh just whatever
right and if you get a nested loop guess
what one of them will be one and one of
them will be another thing
yeah enclosure like closure or the
entire language is the parentheses it's
a lisp
right now these are your father's
parentheses
and
it's a very it's really hard to not see
has anyone used go anyone programming in
go
right a few hands went up okay
so go is
my favorite description of go a chat
called nat price he said it's such an
ugly language the only thing you can do
with it is work
just designed to do working because this
is really ugly language but here's the
thing
go comes with a ships with a with a
formatter called go format
and go format formats your code
and your code now looks like everyone
else's go code
and i'm pretty sure that the whole thing
is just this massive um uh troll right
so what they've done is they said right
we're going to take uh
all the different ways that you could
structure you know where do you put your
curly braces all that kind of thing our
tabs versus spaces and for every single
one we're going to annoy someone
right so i'm not kidding so it uses tabs
for indentation left indentation uses
tabs that's illegal in many states okay
so you just have but then but then if
you have multiple assignments it lines
up all the equals is it puts white space
in i'm like ah
that just appeals to my ocd
i can always forgive the tab thing but
then the curly braces i'm not even going
to tell you
but the thing is right it's wrong for
some value of wrong for everyone and no
one cares
because then all of the tutorial code
you see looks like that all of the
standard library code you see looks like
that all the example code you see and
it's more importantly when you crack
open someone else's code base it looks
like that
a whole load of design a lot of
formatting decisions just got taken off
the table if you don't have that in your
language have that as a standard in your
team
and it's as simple as just putting a
format as you type thing in your idea if
you're using vs code or visual studio or
rider or whatever you're doing you know
whatever you're doing your day job in
have a standard across the team and make
it at least so that it formats it before
it commits
right so that all of the code under
version control looks the same you put
it oh look i could have written that
but then it gets into things like naming
aiming is hard right it gives you things
like naming structure
where you put things all of that stuff
is all idiomatic one of my favorite
examples of an idiom is
um if you go to devon
there's a word in devon for someone
who's not from devon do you know what
that word is
anyone
there's a grockle a grockel is someone
who's not from devon
next door in somerset
there's a word for someone who's not
from somerset do you know what that word
is
it's not grocco
it's emmett
right so two neighboring counties have
this totally different words for and i
for me that is like the epitome of
idiomatic because everyone there knows
what it means
and they're the only people who need to
and technically a grockeal is someone
who doesn't know what a grockeal is
and an emmy it's someone who doesn't
know what an emmett is
right so the same thing
local idioms they may not exist
you may need to retrofit them and this
is sam's you know consistently wrong
right whatever we're doing clearly it
was copied and pasted from one origin
script or whatever
let's at least make everything look like
that and then we can improve it all in
sort of in lockstep
you can only write idiomatic code if you
bother
okay idiomatic code is a choice it's an
investment
i cannot write idiomatic f sharp if i
come straight from c sharp and start
typing
okay i'm going to get a lot of very
c-sharp looking f sharp
yeah
again i can you know and it's when you
shift paradigms like that when you go
from like an oho paradigm into a
functional paradigm you kind of want
mutable state everywhere
you know because that's what you're used
to what do you mean i can't reassign to
a variable it's called a variable dammit
the clue's in the name right what do you
mean it's not
so idiomatic code
and finally domain based
so
joyful code
uses the language of the domain
okay
um i wrote uh i contributed a one thing
to 97 things every programmer should
know and the one thing i contributed was
this code in the language of the domain
and i've got an example in there of like
a a nested map of ins of maps to
instants and and you kind of you unpack
this and and you realize that actually
it's not it's a it's a business rule
about um what they call chinese walls
which is like a privacy thing inside
banks that you're not allowed to see
both sides of a trade which is if you
get it wrong is illegal
you're literally breaking the law right
and this rule and this was a real code
this rule was hidden away in some nested
map of instants because there was
nothing in there about the domain
same code base about six months later
um
and this was i i had a real epiphany
about ddd at this point the main driven
design is there was uh someone leaning
over a desk and there's two programmers
right and they were sitting there
pairing i like pairing it's in a pairing
and there's a trader standing behind an
analyst or something some kind of
financial person
and they were they were discussing how
pricing works pricing of trades and
pricing of trades is a huge complicated
domain
and i i kind of was shoulder surfing and
looking in and i realized something
which is that the programmers were
talking about the code
and the analyst was talking about the
domain
and neither of them noticed
right whoa
yeah because
the domain of the code so naturally
modeled the domain that they collapsed
into the same space
talking about what the code did and
talking about how the domain works were
the same thing
right cognitive load
goes away
i can reason about the problem in code i
manipulate code to make it say what the
domain rule is and then i'm done
right public clock
but not just domain
language domain structure
and this is a this is a big deal
so rich mentioned um
[Music]
uh rails this morning and rails i would
say rails is the progenitor of this
certainly the biggest culprit for this
only because it was so insanely popular
and every framework ever since has done
this it has a boilerplate it'll give you
a template project
and the template project it gives you
has models views controllers helpers
utils
oh loads and loads of stuff um
and and that's where you and it
basically says let's just put your code
in here
and this is this is single
responsibility principle on steroids
right
is that not only is the
the logic for getting my data uh having
business rules
and presenting that data in three
different files they're in three
different directories they're not even
in the same place
they're not even close to each other and
so now what happens is every time i
crack open a rails code base
i learned nothing about the domain
i learned about rails right i already
know that right
i know where i know whether you have
models in music controls i know i'm
going to need these things
but i'd much rather have all of the
payments code together
because that's likely what i'm i'm
unlikely to go and want to change all
the views i'm much more likely to want
to go in and change how payments work
that's much more of a real thing right
and when i change our payments work
because i'm an adult i can get the data
i can process the data and i can present
the data
check me out right because it's not that
hard yeah it turns out and because we
don't have different people in different
teams doing this over eight months
we have the same people co-located all
as buddies going out for lunch together
doing it in eight minutes and at that
point single responsibility separation
of code no longer makes sense in fact it
hasn't since the 90s it hasn't since
refactoring
and again i'll say it again solid when
it came out in the mid 90s much like
scrum when it came out was revolutionary
it was a brilliant set of ideas scrum
said instead of 18 months we're going to
ship in 12 weeks
and we're also going to check in after
six weeks with each other not checking
code we're going to check it after six
weeks to make sure we're on track we're
gonna have a showcase
six week sprints 12 week releases
releasing once a season right was
considered impossible in the early 90s
yeah
so that was brilliant but we're still
suggesting it's good
right 30 years later but we don't we
don't have those constraints anymore
therefore the solution is the solution
to a redundant problem
and also domain boundaries
so this is now about deployability
not necessarily what we deploy but the
options for deployment so
i want domain boundaries to align with
module boundaries to align with units of
deployment boundaries so the payments i
can i can release the payments code
completely independently from the loans
code
i can release subsystems within that
completely independently or i can manage
them completely independently so this
kind of starts to describe an
architectural style
so here we are so we've got um
the cupid then
composable plays well with others unix
philosophy
does one thing and only one thing
and does all of that one thing
idiomatic it feels natural to whom to
someone who isn't you
to someone who is already in that world
whether that is a f-sharp world or a
asp.net world or a c-sharp world or
whatever it is right they are going to
look at that code and they're going to
go
i recognize that
and in your team i really really good
acid test a really good heuristic is
when you look at code you don't know who
wrote it
if you don't know who wrote it you are
epically winning
the idiomatic okay
and domain based
right it's impossible to look at the
code and not know what problem it's
solving
if you don't know what problem it's
solving because it's a map of
instruments you've blown it okay
so how do we apply this
and this is great because again we're a
year into this now i've been talking
about this for a year and i'm getting
feedback and people are saying you know
what i use your keyboard for assessing a
code base
i inherited this code base i'm like what
how much of a mess have i got right i'm
assessing a code base
um i'm going to use cupid to do that and
he started feeding back on twitter about
color i just noticed this and this and
this john skeet is uh building something
in fact he's doing the next talk and the
next slot he's building something for
his church
um an application because that's what
happens when if you go to church and
you're technical you're on the website
yeah if you're a church and you're
accountant you're on the finance right
um
so we're building a building a an
application for them
and and we were chatting and he said you
know what i'm going to use your cupid to
figure out how to do this well or to
figure out what we've already got and
make sense of it so i'm kind of excited
about where that's going
um basis for a code critique
so this is um
this is a deliberate term i've
introduced so who likes code reviews
who does code reviews
yeah there you go so just for for the
for the camera um most people do code
reviews no one likes them uh two people
like them i'm sorry i'm the opposite cam
i love code reviews but i love code
reviews in the david marquez turn the
ship around sense where he talks about
encouraging inspection inviting
inspection
so i use the word code critique because
it's just because it's different words
because it doesn't load isn't loaded so
coker takes like a movie critique it's
like you get a bunch of you around and
you chat about it
and the goal isn't to say what you did
wrong i'm policing your code and you're
wrong and not only are you wrong you're
wrong after the facts and now you have
to go back and fix it all
gotcha no that's mean don't be that
person right
code critique is
maybe we've noticed that two or three
people have been working on similar
things and we've got two or three
different solutions have kind of emerged
in the code base
and so what we as a team are going to do
is say what's our what's our opinion
going to be on that
are we going to take um
john's thing
and then that means that we're going to
have to make the other things kind of
line up to that or we're going to take
daniel's thing and and typically what
happens when you do a code critique in
that way
um you end up with a greater than the
sum of the parts thing like i like what
you did there but there's this other
thing here and whoa and we could make
some observability we can make that
observable by oh not and so now we're
going to change all of them
they're all better and that's very
exciting
okay so code critique is and we're
applying cupid properties to our code
critique
what would make this more composable
right why aren't people using it well
because it drags in this library which
drags in that library which means you've
got to pull in a docker image and oh
crap no wonder can we get rid of it well
hang on
yes
yeah and so on
when you've got legacy code base
okay i use the word scary instead of
legacy so legacy
my working definition of legacy is two
things it is code that is valuable right
it's paying the bills if it's not paying
the bill switch it off oh you can't can
you it's paying the bills right
and you're scared to change it
and you're scared to change it because
not cupid
right because it's massively coupled and
hairy and not intentional revealing any
of those things right
so i've got this big scary code base
where do i start
well i start with one of those
assessments but with a deliberate then
right where's the most you know theory
of constraints which which aspect of
this is giving us the most pain right
now
and because they're all into twingled
it's great because you start making
something more idiomatic and it turns
out to be more predictable
or you know because you're now using
better trolling libraries or whatever or
you start making something more
composable and as you break it apart
each piece becomes more predictable or
more idiomatic so you tend to kind of
get this win-win-win
and then as a syllabus for a programming
course that i haven't written yet
right but absolutely not for
certification
there will be no certification but i
think teaching
young people or people transitioning
into technology
um that these are
the applying these properties that
thinking about these properties will
make code that you will love working in
and that other people will love working
in is a worthwhile endeavor
um
so we're live so what i did is i wrote
it up eventually this article i said
about a year later
and i've now it's 5 000 words and so
what i've done is i've busted it into a
little hugo website cupid.dev
um and keeper.dev is it's a really
simple website it's it says it's hugo
it's markdown um you'll notice there
case studies resources
tbd
very tbd i'm on the lookout for case
studies if you're writing stuff about
this or you're doing stuff or you've
been chatting with your friends or you
make a podcast or something let me know
and i'll put it in here or i'll share
the url to this code base and you can
make a pull request because it's on
github
so so this is there so i'd love you to
have a play with that
and there's also a news group
and the news group is so new that anyone
in this room could be the first post
okay
so there's a key for your code it turns
out there's an awful lot of news groups
called cupid and then nothing to do with
programming
things you discover when you google for
tractors right
so
so that's me and thank you very much for
for coming along and listening
now
i don't know if i'm about to get cut or
if i have time for one question
someone who knows better than me they
haven't stopped me who's got a question
i'll take a question
or i'll suggest you all go get coffee
oh the question is where's the good
coffee it's the far the far left end on
the side there okay
thanks very much